this is the latest generation
mercedes-benz Actros not a rare sight on
German highways but take a look inside
anything not quite right this is the
world's first self-driving series
produced truck the new system is being
tested for the first time on the German
Autobahn until now the self-driving
Actros could only be used in test
conditions manufacturers have been busy
developing the technology for
self-driving vehicles but the government
still has to finalize the legalities
still the governor of the German state
of baden-württemberg who was present for
this trucks maiden voyage is very
optimistic binford coachman explains the
need for politicians to work in parallel
with the car manufacturers there are
whole new legal requirements involved
ascents such as liability for accidents
and other issues he says they need to
keep up with developments to ensure that
politicians encourage progress rather
than slowing it down a year ago Daimler
demonstrated their version for the
future with the aptly named future truck
2025 the driver can even turn around
during the journey and concentrate on
something else entirely
in reality were not quite there yet
in this truck the driver must be able to
take back control in an emergency
explains how the system takes over the
normal driving controls such as steering
braking and accelerating during the long
journeys that a truck driver typically
makes this gives drivers some relief but
they're still fully responsible just as
before they still have to sit and keep
watch over the system he compares it to
an airplane on autopilot the driver can
sit back but still has to be responsible
and stay alert
car Testament oscura would never pass up
a chance to ride in a vehicle like this
he was always taught to have two hands
on the wheel how does the system
actually work he asked costigan tire
before attendances team yeah this is not
in styling her explains that there's an
adaptive cruise control that responds to
what's going on behind and in front of
the vehicle and built-in electric
steering which automatically guides the
vehicle in the lane Mateschitz this fall
so here in their squad Lincoln Lantis
mentions the s-class traffic assist
system and asset that's a good
comparison yes he says that's a good
comparison the relevant information is
delivered via radar sensors and cameras
it's said to be safer than normal
driving because the computer can't get
tired and it seems there are other
benefits once the network is connected
to the Internet and everything's up and
running the traffic eventually so much
better and we'll see a decline in the
level of congestion we experience today
that would be another positive effect he
says because of the way the vehicle is
programmed to drive for example with
even acceleration and braking engineers
hope that there will also be a saving
and fuel of up to 5% the market launch
for the new system is expected in a few
years so you might see driverless trucks
out and about sooner than you think
you